Fred Pleitgen is OUTFRONT in Kiev.
And Fred, air raid sirens,
they were going off earlier today.
No surprise given what's been going on.
But what is it been like on the ground
either, Pamela?
Well, there were some pretty severe drone
and missile attacks by the Russians,
and they pretty much came in two waves.
One was overnight using cruise missiles
and drones.
And the Ukrainians say their air defenses
managed to actually shoot
most of those down.
And then later in the morning,
there were ballistic missile attacks.
And the Ukrainians actually said of
11 ballistic missiles shot
at the capital Kiev.
They managed to take
all of those out now.
Nevertheless, of course, for the folks
who live in the city,
there were some seriously
frightening moments.
Here's what happened.
Terrified children
running for their lives as Russia
unleashed another massive aerial attack
on Ukrainian cities.
But Ukraine says its air
defense managed
to shoot down
all the ballistic missiles
fired at the capital, Kiev.
And now Ukraine's forces
seem nearly ready for their own
much anticipated counter offensive.
This weekend,
Ukraine's top
general, Valery Zelazny,
releasing this video
showing troops gearing up for battle
and showcasing modern western weapons
with a clear message.
It's time to take back what's our income.
We're building a slim.
And that's what these guys
are training for.
This is the unit of the offensive guard
in Ukraine, interior ministry.
We have a clear motivation.
The commander says we defend our land.
This is our nation, our homeland.
The offensive guard is mustering
tens of thousands of troops,
they say,
training to storm trenches
and evacuate casualties,
which they know
they're bound to have
in the tough battles ahead.
But these guys are practicing here.
No doubt will become a reality
for the Ukrainian armed forces
very soon, as Kiev says
it will start a massive counter offensive
to take back all of their territory,
including Crimea.
The Ukrainians already seem
to be stepping up
strikes on possible Russian supply lines
in occupied areas.
Russian installed
officials claiming
Ukrainian missile attacks
against targets around
Berdyansk and Mariupol
in southeastern Ukraine in the past days.
That is to say, it's just the beginning.
A top adviser to Ukraine's
presidency tells me so.
With everything
that is happening
now as a precursor for a counterattack,
a necessary precursor
where the intensity of fire increases.
While for us he's calm
and he lays out
bold aims for the counter offensive
the are online.
It will end undoubtedly
on the borders of Ukraine
as they were
in 1991 with the occupation of Crimea
and with the beginning
of a massive process of transformation
of Russia's political system.
But for now,
resilience remains
key for the people in Ukraine's cities.
These newlyweds had just tied
the knot
and were on their way
to their celebration
when the air raid sirens went off.
So they just continue
to celebrate in the bomb shelter,
vowing not to let Russian rockets ruin
the best day of their lives.
And, you know, Pamela,
that's really
the resilience that we see
from a lot of people here in Kiev.
Of course,
when the sirens go off, the folks,
they do run to the shelters.
They run for cover.
However, they emerge pretty quickly
after the all clear comes in
and they go about their daily
lives, they go straight back to work.
And one of the things
that the head of Ukraine's
military intelligence said today
is he said, look,
if the Russians believe
they can scare the people in Ukraine
and in Kiev specifically,
they certainly are mistaken Pamela.
Well, thank you, Fred.
For now,
former Russian Prime Minister
Mikhail Kasyanov.
He served as prime minister
when Vladimir Putin first
became president.
Thank you for joining us tonight.
You worked alongside Putin
for a number of years.
When you see this new massive
assault of missiles
by Russia into Ukraine,
what do you think Putin
is trying to do right now?
I think Mr.
Putin and
his inner circle,
they are demonstrating
very nervous nervousness.
They're expecting
a Ukrainian counteroffensive operation
and they're nervous about that,
that they're trying to somehow
to prevent on to two
or to make it more difficult, etc..
But of course, these atrocities
just continue to take place.
And people,
people all over the world
already just cannot
keep patience on that.
And everyone
just in the West and the we hope
the Russian Democrats
also expecting just success of Ukrainian
upcoming counteroffensive operation
in Ukraine, meantime, appears
to be stepping up attacks
in Russian occupied territories.
We have seen a number of attacks
by pro-Ukrainian groups inside Russia.
What impact do
those attacks have on Putin
and the Russian public?
I think, of course, it's not obviously
admitted by Ukrainian government
that they involved on these,
but these
these of course, operations
on the territory of Russia,
of course,
demonstrate hitting
some kind of a weakness of border
border control of Russia
or Russian authorities,
and of course, creating some kind of fear
among them on Russia, on Russian army
and population
and also administrations on those regions
and Kremlin.
That is the most important thing.
Just as a demonstration
that Russia is not protected
so much as Putin just declared
for decades, that security and stability
is the major
the major point for and his strategy.
But right now,
just this demonstration
that it's not the case.
Do you see a point
at which Putin will be willing
to negotiate in good faith?
In good faith.
It's interesting expression
of good faith.
But we don't want to negotiate right now.
But he doesn't want to
to talk
to withdraw troops
from occupied territories.
He wants to stop.
He needs the ceasefire so that to
restructure the army and economy
facing problems.
Let's just take a step back for a second.
I mean, when you look at
and listen to Putin now,
how is he different,
if at all, from the person
that you worked with back
in the early 2000?
Oh, absolutely.
That's it's completely different person
at that time
when when we worked together on the first
his charm,
he promised to me
and to all the team of my Cabinet
that he would support
all the all the reforms.
And, in fact,
he implemented this promise.
But the exclusion
of tour reforms,
he didn't allow me
to undertake administrative reform,
which means
reduction of state involvement
in the economy, in the public life, etc..
And he didn't allow me to to pursue.
But this your gas sector reform.
It means just to
destroy Gazprom monopoly
for gas supplies.
But at that time, we no way
I understand
he pretended
to be a democratically devoted person,
but in fact, he was always a KGB agent.
Right now,
he performs as he is a natural person.
Putin's KGB
agent with absolute death,
distorted worldview.
All right.
Thank you so much for your time.
We appreciate it. Thank you.
And OUTFRONT now, retired Army Lieutenant
General Mark Hertling, former
commanding general of Europe
and the seventh Army.
So you just heard there
from the former prime minister Kasyanov,
saying that those massive strikes
overnight show
how nervous Putin
and his inner circle are about this
coming offensive.
From a military standpoint,
what would Russia
be trying to do with those strikes?
And they're trying to interfere
with the connection
between the political body
and the decision makers
in the key government.
President Olinsky, with his field
generals, General Zalewski,
they have developed a plan.
There has been messaging
on the Internet today
saying that
that President Zelensky
has approved that plan.
Now, I think Russia is really
it's not just
going after Ukraine,
as the former prime
minister has now said,
it's more to try and interfere
with the command and control structure
between the political leaders in Kiev
and the frontline generals
of all along the front line.
And there's a reporting out there
that we talked about earlier
in the show where
some of these
the missiles are using
or millions of dollars a piece.
I mean, this is precious
arsenal for Russia.
What do you make of that?
Well, it certainly is for Russia.
And they are running out
of these missiles.
But there have been reports
that they've been running out
for a long time.
You happen to mention
that some of these Russian missiles
cost millions of dollars.
The missiles that shoot them
down, the Patriot missiles
also cost
millions of dollars
between three and 4 million a copy.
So it really is a race to logistics,
a race to technological advantage.
And I think what happened last night
with the drone strikes
accompanying missile
strikes in the evening
and then further
ballistic missiles during the day.
Again, it's Russia
attempting to attempt to to template
what Ukraine is doing
in their defensive positions
and then trying to get the faster
moving missiles,
the more damaging missiles
into the capital city.
So it's a tactic
of, you know,
we're hearing reports of 90 missiles
or whatever.
But the way they're being
shot into the different locations
in Ukraine,
Russia is attempting to interfere
with manning
control structure
as well as troop movements
within Ukraine.
So it is a back and forth
and it can't just be the
the big tactic of,
hey, we're shooting a lot of missiles.
It's really interesting
with the Patriot missiles
because as you'll recall,
there was so much back
and forth and reluctance
from the Biden administration
to send the Patriot missiles.
Now they're over there, as Wolinsky says.
They're using them
and they're saving lives.
If you had a bird's eye view of Ukraine,
what clues
would you be looking for to see if
Ukraine was about to start its offensive?
Well, you know,
there's a strategic objective
that President Olinsky has,
and he has
given that to his military commanders.
And over the last
several months and weeks,
they have been shaping the battlefield.
We've used that term
multiple times on here.
Now it's time for the military commanders
to come back to the president
and say, hey, look, boss,
we have looked at the battlefield.
Here's where the Russians are weak.
Here's where we need to be strong.
Let's start moving forces from there.
There are longer areas
in the rear of Ukraine
into their attack positions.
So I think what we're going to see
in the next couple of days
and weeks
is a lot of movement of Ukrainian forces.
They are going to try and hide
that movement the best they can.
And at the same time,
they're going to try and deceive Russia
for where they are going
and what axis of advance
they're going to use.
So a lot of this,
Pamela, is a lot like a chessboard.
Both sides are playing chess.
They're trying to beat the other one
to get to the right position
so they can conduct the kind of offensive
and defensive operations they need.